now we just got an amazing sizzle reel
with a couple teases for we're gonna be
seeing in season two but you left us
with one heck of a cliffhanger when our
man showed up and we learned that the
Justice Society of America exists in the
flare overs
now how is the JSA going to figure into
season two what can you tell us
producers Phil well the JSA you know
even heroes have heroes and for us the
JSA is you know it's like that Golden
Age generation of superheroes and for
our team you know it's kind of like a
bunch of you know modern people meeting
that Greatest Generation it's it's a
it's a story of you know if ours is a
family it's it's like getting to meet
your grandfather's and maybe
grandmothers and realizing that they
were they were real superheroes which is
not to take anything away from our guys
but you know we think Phil well you know
we have an unconventional way of doing
things on our team and it's uh you know
for some of you it's something to look
up look up to like for Brandon for you
Dom it's people who just annoy you now
that's a really good tease for the JSA
but we want to know who are gonna meet
will you tell us which Justice Society
members we're going to be seeing in
season two okay fine um doctor midnite
Stargirl I should Angela her obsidian a
lot of a thing I was most afraid of is
happening I'm forgetting wait up
commander steel not to be confused with
citizen steel ooh and have a left anyone
else I think well well I guess there's
someone at the table Lincoln if you've
already alleged in my mind and vixen now
sneaking a victim and vixen and citizen
seal we have two new faces on this panel
with us today welcome Nick and Maisy hi
we're very excited to get to know you in
season two and actually amazing you just
met the rest of your cast yesterday
right anyone started filming yet Nick
only has three days under his belt but
but for both of you and for our
producers what can you tease of what
these two new characters are going to
bring to the legends dynamic oh man I
just don't want to mess anything up um
it's funny um I spent three days working
so far and I had a moment with Victor
because I always wanted to work with
Victor really yep and I had a moment
where was I was doing the scene with him
I was looking at him and and I there was
silence after he started talking and I'm
staring at him and he looked at me and
said your turn and we picked it up but
uh more than anything I'm just excited
to work with everybody when we get into
the trenches and you know not spoil any
more secrets for one day here at
comic-con my first question I had today
at comic-con I've never done this before
but I'm sitting behind mark and somebody
asked me a question and I answered it
and this was what I saw from mark that's
not true there's a line is a slide
we were sitting next to each other he
did that amazing what are you excited
about in joining this team this season
well I think it's just nice to have some
new energy in the team and just to shake
things up a little bit and I guess we
analyze what it means to be a superhero
both ways the Justice Society of America
and our guides really sort of challenge
that and push each other to really go
and save the world I guess and I don't
know if we've officially said this
before but we're going to say there
today this is your season two lineup of
legends of tomorrow so let's give them a
big round of applause so like are they
far as a lot of characters in addition
new characters make characters from
shows that we love like flash and arrow
and you know hopefully hopefully we'll
get some Supergirl people in the near
future when we see how everything mixes
together some of the fun is seeing those
crossovers and and seeing these
characters interact with the other shows
so mark and Phil can you tease are we
gonna be seeing some familiar faces this
season I mean within the first frames
yeah I mean it right out of the gate we
we're blending these worlds so you're
not gonna have to wait long just wait to
use the bathroom till at least the first
commercial break well who are you gonna
see mark oh we're gonna see miss not
even ml playing holla per queen yeah
right from the very beginning
uh actually mayor Oliver Queen
so no go see in this time around no
we're slowly moving in that direction
all right anyone else anyone else we're
gonna be seeing this year well I think
we might have caught a little glimpse
there in that sizzle reel of uh yeah
McDonough playing mr. damian darhk--
he's gonna return for our season
premiere he's you know he's you know
we've got 122 years for us to play with
so we're gonna meet him in 1942 that's
why he's looking so dapper in that in
that trailer now I feel like really
asking this cuz you just gave us two
amazing ones but is there anyone else we
can expect that you can tell us today
ooh
Phil you wanna well should we bring
somebody out oh wait no not yet but we
heard you having real depe sowed six
Phil episode six huh
I forgot that one okay oh no I'm gonna
take it yeah we have Jonah Hex is
returning well that's a good day I mean
that's that's a lot of excitement right
at the top of this panel yeah to our
returning cast members are returning
legends looking back at season one you
guys went on so many adventures so many
time periods so many settings what was
the moment when you guys as a cast began
to feel like yeah yeah we're a team we
are the superhero team the legends of
tomorrow do you feel that way yet
pinpoint a moment is is challenging I
think the whole season was not only for
the for the characters but for us as
actors to to and to become friends and
to create our unity it's a season long
process I don't there was one moment but
it was it was we definitely felt I think
things beyond gel around Episode eight
nine it was kind of I think an evolution
I think the show as the show evolves you
know you find different relationships
that there are that are have a specific
specificity and and a meaning and and
the writers pick up on that and then
they they they write for that
that'd be those two people but also I
think it's just over time you know you
just get more comfortable with each
other and so I think there was it was
pretty quick though that we all just
felt like oh we know how to do this and
and and we're still evolving which was
the coolest thing now we have two new
wonderful people and well so it'll just
hopefully get better and better
now Dom looking back at season one Rory
went through quite an evolution over the
course of the season from the person who
we knew coming coming from other
familiar shows to the person who we
ended with so what was your favorite
part of this new version of your
character and what do you like best
about him a new version meaning this
year or last year the the person who we
ended up with sort of the personality
the persona who we ended season one with
oh I'm not sure he's he's a little more
serious
any-any just lost his best friend he's
had to say goodbye to uh okay now all
right yeah
no you're caught back up yeah I'm just
trying to remember what the last episode
was last year um yeah he was pissed that
snart left and right now it's all about
him I think this year that looming
shadow has gone from him I mean snart
was the boss and I think Rory this year
is gonna be even more outrageous than he
was last year now friends and Viktor the
firestorm duo has been through a lot
since since their days on the flash and
you know when we see them back together
at the end of season one they're ready
for for a new adventure and Jax is
pretty much kicking Martin out the door
at that point do you think that they are
are at a good place you think there's
something that can break them apart at
this point are they really the dynamic
duo and what is the most fun for the two
of you for getting a seem partner like
that and someone who get to play off um
for for the firestorm dynamic I thought
we started off we're at loggerheads a
lot at the time I was very tumultuous
but but we
Groo evolved and we just kind of became
a cohesive unit and that's where we kind
of all we're on the same page at the
moment how long that lasts for is
another story but um but yeah we're like
we're know we're in a good place okay
France I can't listen to a word you say
without looking at that tight so that is
a cool it's like it's amazing
oh yeah thought I'd be a bit of subtle
today yeah yeah I'm keeping it low-key
and Victor for you what what is the fun
for you of being able to have another
half of your superhero identity who you
get to journey along with well you know
I've had I've had two other halves this
is my second one and I thought it would
be very difficult to to go on without
Robbie and then I met friends and Robbie
has been eclipsed oh no no no that was a
joke
and he knows uh but I have to say this
boy is so talented and so intimidatingly
smart and funny and and gives so much on
stage and off that it's been kind of a
thrill to work with him
and it continues to be that way and some
of my favorite moments in the first
season were when when Martin was was
assumed he was right and was completely
I'm very parental and very dogmatic
about his about telling him how to
behave and then being proven wrong by
him and so that's that dynamic is always
interesting to me and will continue in
various ways because no matter how well
we're getting along there's there's egos
involved and there'll be they'll be at
each other's throats any minute so I'm
actually loving working with this fellow
and I hope I hope that continues
I paid him to say that
now Sara in some interviews or hung Katy
apologies Katy I know I'm just confusing
you with with the white canary which how
can you not at this point you've so
embodied the character Katy you've
teased that we can expect maybe some
romance for Sarah in this half of the
season which I I feel like at this point
you've just sort of made happen you're
like hey Phil and Mark this is how
you're gonna write what's happening for
Sarah in the romance department what can
you tease of what we might be it might
be seeing this season I don't know if
it's so much romance yet as we are just
Sarah's like kind of a player she's
having fun she's a little bit of a
Casanova uh which is cool and we've been
having a good time with it and you know
I did say I did asked I said well you
know I'd love for Sarah to get a nice
girlfriends coming up so we'll see
though you know it's it's kind of hard
to find love when you're traveling
through time on a spaceship but somehow
Sarah you know seems to be making time
so it's good well speaking of having
some trouble with uh with love and space
Brandon ray-ray red I would have been
striking out with the ladies that he's
been pursuing so far um moving on after
you know he had to say goodbye to Kendra
we all had to say goodbye to the Hawks
in season one could one wish for Ray's
journey in season two what would it be
one wish for Ray's journey um that's a
big question
- to unite unite the team even more and
to be the the well-oiled machine that
that they can be so that they can all
ride off into the sunset and and save
the day
well I mean if it was rep to ray he
would he would he would he would
vanquish all evil on episode 1 but then
it wouldn't we would have a season we
wouldn't have a show and we have a full
season this year so we need to fill it
up with lots of conflict now Arthur ripp
was our de facto leader of the legends
Joe's oh that's your time ripp was our
de facto leader of the legends yes
season 1 but we learned that he may be
lied to some of his co-pilots a little
bit in season 1 everyone else is sort of
coming to their own as a team and when
we catch back up with them you've said
everyone's gonna be even more of a team
so do you imagine that he's gonna sort
of stay in the leadership position
there's a good question I think I think
he'd definitely like to he definitely
sees himself as there he's not very good
is he he's like he's really really
messed up with them and then lost his
family like when we meet him I think
he's like I I feel he's like a
disappointed parent because you know
they're on the ship and they keep
messing everything up because they're
there or they just want to take in their
egos or take them off on their own
adventures and he's like he's got the
point where just yeah well so I'm not
angry with you I'm just really
disappointed in you all but then we get
quite a big twist quite early on with
him which changes everything which I
can't talk about describe but yeah
there's a quite an exciting
big twist for him early on that's a good
tears okay now let's get another big
round of applause for two new cast
members Nick and Maisie
get yet again we know you guys haven't
you have not gotten in at all in Macy's
behalf into season 2 or very early on
but given what you've seen of season 1
who do you expect your characters both
click best with and clash most with
that's a good one I feel uh I mean I've
done a couple scenes with Dom already
and I felt like I clicked but then again
it's like a blind date for an actor when
you do what in your like I liked you did
you like me he's wondering why you
haven't called him yeah Dom hasn't
texted me back yet
and then for character wise I feel I
feel maybe Oh Sarah and I may clash
mm-hmm yeah maybe I don't know I'm
guessing physics no that's my good that
way you guys have seated so far apart
right maybe just in case yeah I
requested that how amazing what about
for Ben
I think vixens gonna struggle a bit with
Rory at the sort of anti-hero and
struggling with understanding how how is
he actually a good guy um and to gel
with I think it's probably Sarah I think
I'm gonna say I'm better saying that
barrel you better save me very strong
independent women who've been parts of
massively male-dominated teams so it's
either going to be a gelling or big
clash will be interesting to find out
now to to our producers you guys have
said before that the question of season
two is and this is a quote from from
Phil I think we determined it's from
Phil is if the legends don't belong here
where do they belong how much is that
question going to inform their journey
in season two well you know season two
is it you know they're almost victims of
their own success you know at the end of
season one everything that they set out
to do in the pilot they achieve they
save the world and they vanquished
Vandal Savage and they avenge the death
of rhipsalis family yeah
what yeah yeah but it's in me what do
you do next after you climbed Everest
what is it there left to conquer and you
know the irony is but by destroying the
time masters our guys are now left
holding the bag time has been left
unguarded and now all manner of time
pirate time criminal time douchebag is
that these people are now running
rampant and our team who I mean they
don't look like law enforcement they
don't act like law enforcement now
they're in charge of guarding all of
history which makes you sort of worry
about history
we're worried but you did mention I mean
we did defeat Vandal Savage at the end
of season 1 as our big goal the Legends
accomplished it which leaves open the
big question of what's going to happen
in season 2 what can you guys tell us
about the threat that we're going to be
facing that the legends are going to be
facing this year well it's going to be
much more mysterious you know we sort of
in last year in the pilot we knew
everything we knew the what when where
how of you know and we are trying to
stop this one incident you know season 2
is predicated much more on mysteries and
little mysteries and instead of one bad
guy you know the idea of the multiple
you know the responsible for for not
just saving the world but fixing these
things called aberrations where where
people mess with the fabric of time and
our guys are obliged to correct it
wait so multiple would I say that you
said multiple villains can we know who
they're gonna be
I said a mark call mark can we find out
what the villains are man season two if
you guys cheer loud enough can we
convince mark to tell us who the
villains are gonna be in season two
that's pretty good guys okay well okay
here's the thing if you're gonna have a
team of superheroes you got to fight a
team of super villains um so we're gonna
start off with Matt Lesher reprising his
role as eobard thawne the reverse-flash
so you also saw in our teaser trailer
that neal mcdonough is back as damian
darhk-- everybody who watched episode 15
knows that Leonard snart is dead but
everyone who watched episodes 1 through
16 knows that it's a time-travel show so
that means we can bring back Wentworth
Miller as Captain Cold
hey and there's one more and I'm
probably forgetting who it is yeah I
need some help I maybe could he come out
and tell me I've had a little bit of
experience with time travel
so I expect I'll I'll fit in just fine
Malcolm Merlyn
you gotta see for you and everything
John we're all ready thank you your guys
why was this the right choice I mean
it's so brilliant we have we have what
the Legion of Doom basically we've
assembled we call it the Legion of Doom
yeah why was this the right move for for
the villains into the cast what are you
guys most looking forward to in fighting
some familiar faces who we just need to
knock down we just need to defeat them
for good at this point it gives us a
massive challenge like I think it's
gonna be I think it's gonna be amazing
I'm very excited about working with John
finally yeah it's it means that it's
gonna take quite a while to defeat them
which is great because we've got a lot
of that besides to do yeah I'm excited
because I Sarah really wants to kill
these oh yeah I mean you killed me or
had someone well technically my daughter
did it yeah but that was you and damian
darhk--
i am very excited to get my hands on him
I'm just very I'm very hey I'm a huge
fan of the show by the way and I you
know I I watched you guys and I think
it's amazing I love the fact that that
you've brought time-travel also to a
different level in that aspect and like
I you know I know Arthur from another
show what's gonna be interesting like
you guys said you know Ray Palmer the I
knows Malcolm Sara knows Malcolm so
there's gonna be some dynamic there with
them and I'm really intrigued because I
don't know you know we're not talking
about anything really what's happening
but it's interesting to see how I'll fit
in and interact with everybody else and
who might be someone that he likes and
he doesn't like and all that sort of I'm
really excited really hope you like me
John I really want to do a scene with
you yeah I really do it's time I really
do
you